President Trump is trying to start a new
chapter in his administration with a new
chief of staff
General John Kelly was sworn in minutes
ago in the Oval Office
president Trump named Kelly to replace
Reince Priebus on Friday Kelly was the
president's Secretary of Homeland
Security his new job is to bring
discipline to a White House in turmoil
and help the president get his stalled
agenda on track major Garrett is at the
White House
major good morning good morning Kelly's
arrival here of course creates a vacancy
at the top of Homeland Security his
deputy Elaine Duke will hold that post
until of course a new nominee is named
in a Senate confirmation process is
completed President Trump spoke
favorably of his new chief of staff
denouncing he would replace Ryan's
previs who helped draft Kelly into the
administration Kelly a retired four-star
Marine Corps general is tasked with
bringing discipline and professionalism
to the warring West Wing that means
controlling access to the president and
organizing decision-making a contrast to
the president's own volatile approach
mr. Trump is fired a national security
adviser and FBI director and a holdover
acting Attorney General and his press
secretary communications director deputy
chief of staff deputy national security
adviser and legal team spokesman have
all resigned he was right to hit the
reset button and I think that it was an
it was something that I think the White
House and needs I think it's healthy
Priebus whose influence inside the White
House had been in decline for weeks
accepted the inevitable budget director
Mick Mulvaney offered this theory I
think the president wants to go a
different direction wants a little bit
more discipline a little more structure
in there there was no sign Kelly's
arrival slowed the president's Twitter
habits mr. Trump unloaded 13 tweets on
Saturday including hits on Republicans
for failing to repeal and replace
Obamacare saying they looked like quote
fools you have to let Trump be Trump
that is former campaign manager Corey
Lewandowski said Kelley should
understand
the president's instincts are fixed that
is what has made him successful over the
last 30 years that is what the American
people voted for and anybody thinks are
gonna change Donald Trump doesn't know
Donald Trump contenders to replace Kelly
at Homeland Security include Texas
Congressman Mike McCaul White House
Homeland Security Advisor Tom Foster the
Acting Director of immigration customs
and enforcement Tom Holman and a
longshot Attorney General Jeff Sessions
his name was raised this weekend but
several sources Charlie tell us that is
unlikely major a Peter Baker talked to
Jim Baker sort of the gold standard for
being chief of staff Baker said it
depends on how well you do depends on
whether you emphasize the chief or the
staff what attributes both good and bad
does John Kelly bring to this job well
let's talk about advantages one of the
reasons that Reince Priebus was around
for so long as president Trump could not
find a replacement he really wanted now
he has one and everyone here knows that
and all the warring factions at least
for now are making all the right noises
about wanting to follow Kellis lead he
also doesn't have any of the embedded
loyalty questions that arose around
Reince Priebus during the campaign when
after that Access Hollywood tape broke
Priebus was one of the few in the
campaign inner circle to suggest the
president he might want to step out of
the campaign that never left Priebus is
as far as loyalties questions were
raised about him advantages also that
kelly has the next big issue for this
White House tax reform the president and
the Treasury Secretary will take Lily
there disadvantages he has no
relationship really on Capitol Hill and
he has no real experience with all these
warring factions if they turn against
each other yet again but the president
loves generals he does indeed thanks
major
you got it